the Mando BR set has many intriguing
features but its biggest mysteries lie
in its complex fractal
boundary zooming in to different
boundary regions reveals some astounding
features a valley of
seahorses parades of
elephants and miniature versions of the
set itself so we can sort of keep
finding Nest a sequence of smaller and
smaller M BR sets all one inside of the
next here at the bound mathematicians
are probing for answers as you look at
it it sort of seems like one blob but if
you really ask like is it all connected
or maybe if I zoom in Far Enough there's
some separating piece this question is
Central to a 40-year-old problem called
the Mando BR locally connected
conjecture or
mlc if the set is locally connected that
means that no matter what point you
choose to examine or how far you zoom in
the area will always look like one nice
connected section